francia cuna de la ilustración y hogar
del wii pastor cuenta con una de las
mayores cantidades de detractores de la
vacuna en el mundo según una encuesta de
ipsos uno de cada dos franceses no tiene
intenciones de vacunarse
es porque no tengo ninguna confianza en
el gobierno o el comité científico veo
la vacuna un poco prematura y la
enfermedad ha existido por poco tiempo
nos dijeron que una vacuna tardaría años
pero como por arte de magia tenemos una
vacuna para todo el mundo así que por lo
tanto no estoy a favor
sabemos que llevan muchos años producir
una vacuna y aquí en tres meses
obtenemos una vacuna así que tal vez sea
efectiva pero tengo dudas hasta que
tengamos los datos por escrito como
dicen algunos expertos y no la
conseguiré el escepticismo de la nación
es importante para el presidente manuel
bacón que prometió una estrategia
transparente en francia- la profunda
desconfianza hacia la clase política
parece estar directamente relacionada
con la disposición a aplicarse o no una
vacuna podemos ver muy claramente que
hay una correlación muy fuerte entre la
confianza de la gente en las autoridades
políticas y científicas y la aceptación
de la vacunación en francia tenemos a
nivel estructural una desconfianza muy
fuerte hacia las diferentes
instituciones políticas que es bastante
específica en francia y que no se
encuentra en otros países europeos
la baja aceptación de la vacuna podría
dejar a francia vulnerable a futuras
olas durante la pandemia y podría
comprometer la recuperación de la
segunda economía más grande de la zona
euro pero marco sabe que no puede
presionar a una población que tiene una
desconfianza muy arraigada en el estado
y donde muchas personas miran con
sospecha a las multinacionales
farmacéuticas